we have I've stole from my own
grandmother you know I've stole from
people out of the most
I'm not there for my daughter I don't
know my kid and it's it's funny because
I don't all this fancy stupid [ __ ] I get
every day you only get about 5% of what
you take is a thief that you know and if
the job we're doing I like I had a
stepdad growing up he was like well-off
and his family's well-off but they
worked their asses off to get there and
they always said this one thing you know
it was a job worth doing is worth doing
well
so if I'm gonna be a shitty person
I thought be good at it you know and so
I've taken that kind of philosophy to
the point of going into some of the most
secured financial businesses and
districts across the country and
Exploited their security flaws and then
had 15 laptops and not a single person
would touch him because they just came
out of some wherever that hell and
you're like Danna I just put in eight
hours carried about a hundred pounds
where the gear and I can't sell a single
[ __ ] laptop you don't mean it's
unlocked I unlocked it my damn self it
makes you feel like damn I put in a lot
of [ __ ] work dude for uh for nothing
so then you get to the frustrating part
of your life were you to say you know
what [ __ ] you if it's not if nobody
wants it then I'm just gonna destroy at
least I know where my work starts and
ends you know I'm not gonna leave all
these loose ends but doing that and to
think of like when I was working and how
much money I put in the taxes
and then the see what people do with
that tax money I worked so hard for it's
such a [ __ ] it's so confusing you know I
don't know what to where to start you
know like I'm 27 and are using drugs oh
yeah yes that week I got told my buddy I
pretty much any drug I guess the really
drug I don't really find a need for is
cocaine believe it or not I've never
seen the glory in spending a crazy
amount of money on nothing I don't get
it I've been using a lot it started out
as you know smoking weed at like 13 you
know 12 13 years old that I didn't smoke
cigarettes at all until I was 18 so
start out we died like 12 13 and then it
went to ecstasy at like 15 and then it
was like once I tried a couple of them I
was just like yes this is awesome
I'm gonna just do this [ __ ] all the time
so they have progressed on like eating
MDMA or MDA until I was about 17 is 13
1/2 and then that's when the really
cheap meth craze really hit up I'm from
in Seattle
and so it hit around 17 18
and then I went into that I got the
opportunity because I started slipping
up and I knew better I got this phone
call from my uncle he said what say hey
you want a better job because I was
working at a discount tire company and
he said yeah I got a job for you waiting
it right now 2750 an hour to start I'm
like no [ __ ] I can do the right thing
make money and go kick some ass you know
so I went out to North Dakota and I made
seventy two hundred dollars my first
paycheck and I and I stayed clean off of
uh amphetamines and I took pain pills on
occasion but I never really chased it
you know and uh at that point so I spent
all my money on partying with alcohol
and stuff like that and then about a
month and a half into working in the oil
field out and North Dakota my uncle who
is my crew chief yeah I saw I was
starting to get exhausted you know I was
170 pounds and good you know mildly
decent shape I never made it I didn't
graduate high school I dropped out of
high school I was 15 but I was in like
that standard non going to any physical
education a typical teenager build you
know it's tall and gangly and stuff and
I remember like it was yesterday he
passed me back to this little pipe or
everything and I hit it like twice and I
was so spun because it was route before
this meth now DS is real cranker ever
they call it from the middle BFE you
know you know I was hooked
like straight hook
and when I was 18 I spent it was 200
hours I spent $30,000 33,000 and about a
month in it like a month in a week ish
on crank yeah real cranky and [ __ ]
partied my ass I've had a great time for
reluctant like the next year straight
and then I ran out of money I lost my
job because I could not be stable and
made me actually
damn near schizophrenic King made me go
crazy and chasing women and stuff next
thing you know I'm broke living at my
grandma's instant in Washington again
have a girlfriend with me that crazy
beautiful but she's starting to you know
I'm not putting in her face at all she's
just there so you know she's doing it
and wondering what the [ __ ] am i doing
yeah so did your family earlier yeah my
mom is situation yeah my mom um she's an
addict as well my whole family on one
side of my family they're all going
through addiction really bad yeah my
cousin just died my cousin Brian rest in
peace um he's like my he's a good dude
that guy can steal any car with any key
I've ever seen I've never seen it before
I've tried thousands of times he can hop
in a Jeep with the Toyota key and start
right up that's just a damn miracle they
didn't like they could come in handy if
it's 30 below zero and you're about to
die but like in in a practical sense
it's horrible you know I mean but
he was born into it kind of as well and
like my mama's cleanest over for ten
years
first like memories I have in my life is
going to treatment with her for like a
year you know I grew up in a treatment
facility and my mom this used to be a
stripper and like she's really pretty
you know and she always had the the dude
you know she always had to dude you know
and thought that its attention was
better than what I guess society deems
as their correct thing no whatnot but um
so I lost a lot of it I didn't really
get to know my mom only like I'm long
level you know I got been or as like a
friend and I always had these dudes
doing out of my life and then she
finally needs this dude in treatment of
course and falls in love with him and
he's on this righteous path of getting
right she wants that but she doesn't you
know so it's like yeah do you mind if I
put on okay um anyways I I watched my
mom go from living at these brownies
couches and random places to me I'm
sitting here and watching my family
become a family and we went from the
one-bedroom apartment to the three
bedroom or the two bedroom and then for
the two bedrooms to the the house the
first house and then I watched my
parents finally get their dream house
and build it but they weren't happy you
know something was always off and when
they would have a problem it felt like
they always place blame on me you know
and so I left the house early as a kid I
was gone I was like all right you guys
have issues I'm tired of feeling bad for
myself for another reason it you know so
I'm gonna fill that void with drugs
and because the fact is is that I don't
have all the money in the world
and you guys are very like
weird about your money I'm gonna have to
get a laptop for school cuz I got into a
good school you know so I started out
with stealing - for my education was
originally a lot of stole but then I got
caught by my parents with having a
stolen laptop from school and they made
me turn it in and do the right thing and
I end up getting completely kicked out
of that school for it and then after
that I was like [ __ ] school I'm gonna go
to work so I got my GED when I was
fifteen I went to work and got my I
rented a room from these people who are
in the military at 15 I had two jobs was
about to get into the military which I
thought I could with the GED and then I
threw it all away I got in a DUI it I
hit a fire hydrant
and became a meth addict Skid Row um I
pulled into town I stole four cars I had
a dream of going to LA right and I fell
in love she broke you know I broke my
own heart really and I needed a way down
here and being paranoid and always
thinking every Big Brothers afternoon or
whatever the hell I ended up carrying
four cars four different vehicles
God says San Francisco and realized I'm
not gonna try and do that anymore cuz
it's not being successful so so I ended
up catching a greyhound down here about
two two and a half weeks ago
it got off the Greyhound and ran in to
my first I guess event which was walking
down the street
trying to find some drugs to smoke
because I had $10 in my pocket last ten
bucks and this do you bought you know
doing this thing on the street corner
he's like hey I was like hey dude I'm
trying to find you know I need some
speed or it ever he said yeah yeah and
and I'm making a good friend in being on
the streets I'm figuring it out out here
without any resources no cell phone
nothing literally which is closing my
back um I dressed in a suit and tie some
mainly and I try to clean up this
humanly possible as much and I go into
those really big skyscrapers and I walk
in and I go and wait for somebody to
just not pay attention and I slide to
the back and take an emergency stairwell
up to the 20th floor and a butter knife
Papa you know just a butter knife opens
the door from the street scary long Dan
yeah full access to multi millions of
dollars worth of resources it's
incredible and so I'll go and just a
notary stamp in a picture of a signature
just know it looks like and with their
CODIS and then notary stamp gets you
unlimited amount of money all right walk
out with I walked out with 15 laptops
the other day why yeah but walking right
out in front of them not even trying to
hide it in a student I yes it's
incredible
and then come down to skid row and get
rid of them for pennies on the dollar
anonymously yeah it's a lot of work I
mean I got cellulitis in my leg I
probably need to get my leg amputated if
I don't like keep taking care of it so I
mean yeah hopefully getting back
together with your kids or your that's
that's honestly that's what I'm doing
this for it sounds crazy but I hit I I
came upon quarter-million dollars in
gold last year and I [ __ ] it all off
and didn't realize what I had because I
was inpatient and I was also you know
playing the game they call it in
how'd you come across to her ability I
broke into a house and I don't really
ever do that no this came out of a car
sadly I don't again it's not like I
break windows I don't like to do any of
that kind of [ __ ] but like a Rolex only
got me 400 bucks
mm-hm you know in San Francisco of all
places you know um you know it I like to
play Robin Hood like I go and I take
advantage of this white privilege [ __ ]
because it is real and I see people out
here who who genuinely truly try their
hardest to survive and not just to
survive but to keep a level head into
like it's inspiring to see how some of
these people can live and keep a
positive mindset because I've always
been a really positive person and going
through like my trials and tribulations
I like being happy and I like when the
world is happy too and like we're all in
a harmony you know and it sucks to have
to be that guy but you know I do pretty
good about keeping my guilt from like
get me know it's like once every three
weeks or so I'll break down cuz my guilt
my conscience will is it's not like I
sleep at night have nightmares or
nothing but I've died six times in my
life you know been brought back
accidental overdose cuz I don't use
needles um just smoking this fentanyl
[ __ ] here in town it's the most deadly
thing I've ever seen in my life here
I've been smoking drugs forever I hate
it one time a week ago I hit it one hit
killed me um then purposeful overdose
and done that twice I hated myself I
fell in love and it wasn't able to be a
man
I feel like I deserve to be so I tried
killing myself and they didn't work so
stop trying that I died from exhaustion
I was climbing buildings in rappelling
through the skylights and stealing saves
and all by myself
in the middle of the pouring rain I
broke two ribs in my back and suffocated
myself um yeah rappelling off I'm
holding slip I also just up just a few
other ways you know like but my heart
gave out just one time and I had a
felony warrant and I was so spooked that
I was gonna go to jail you know I was
going through a really rough time with
my heroin addiction and I was dope sick
I was looking for anything anything to
help me get that next fix and I'm riding
my bike down down this International
Boulevard pacific highway that goes all
way from Mexico to Canada pretty much I
was riding on Pacific Highway in I felt
like this weird flutter and my right leg
had been acting up like swelling up in
him and stuff so my right leg it swollen
up probably got two-thirds at the time
as sighs it isn't out like one in two
third sighs and my left arm went no I'm
sorry tingling and all of a sudden like
claps and I have like no energy you
couldn't move and that was the first
time I really did die like and it scared
the [ __ ] and I had a dream about it
twice that week that I was gonna die
yeah and next thing you know BAM who did
I wake up to this guy going like this
Chetan you know Justin Bullard boom I
hopped up
I was like thinking it was gonna be the
EMT now it's got up and ran didn't even
care what direction I left my bike and
everything I just [ __ ] ran and I made
about 20 feet and then I collapsed hit
the ground again music relax relax you
don't love was like ah [ __ ] and I was
all scuffed up cuz I was riding a bike
and when I collapsed it you know
barzmann sideways and I fell and stuff
and so I'm bleeding on my face and I was
like yeah I called it he's like I called
the ambulance about like how long you
know about seven years ago oh [ __ ] it's
time to go you know and so I grabbed my
stuff and got back up to Seattle and got
my girl fix Ritter what the [ __ ] I had
but it was a pretty traumatic experience
what caused that exhaustion no
nourishment lack of sleep lack of yeah
in the drugs you know affecting heart
rate and blood pressure or ever do you
think your your upbringing your
childhood your mom's addiction all the
family addition he's kind of would put
you on this path in a weird way yeah um
I know the difference between right
right and wrong you know being that I
grew up around her a lot of bad and then
was you know what school and everything
which I teach me was right so like going
back and forth my uncle he's a big
influence mine like I I remember is like
the first memory of my life going to my
grandma's house hanging out my mom was
like slumped out been asleep for three
four days and everybody's partying at my
grandma's downstairs basement getting
high and [ __ ] and I was a kid you know
three years old four years old and in
marshmallow uncle come in with the sack
100 our bills like that he's a classy
help me count this you know I don't like
okay you know as a kid like yeah I'd let
me get some you know sick no no no well
my grandma runs the state business takes
care of development only disabled people
and she's an angel she's an angel but
you know that doesn't pay the bills
being an angel and so the business that
she was running was in a wealthier part
of the Seattle Eastside and my uncle
going to school well because he would
get hami down closing stuff these people
were driving around and BMWs in freshman
year you know and he got made fun of me
he's like yeah tired of it you know I'm
just taking a stand for myself so you
know you didn't he would he had the gift
of gab he would hustle these people out
of everything but just the words and and
uh he's a clean-cut you know
clean-cut dude and then it became next
thing you know my grandma's house is
getting raided by the feds
he's got caught with a pound of meth at
19 years old me believe he's at 19 yeah
your family no yeah no and it's like I
don't I know that they're what the
alchemists uncle spent 20 years in
prison on and on I have no relationship
with him I've seen seen him beat the
hell out of some people you know women
and men
I don't want to be that guy there's no
need I want to do something that like
changes the world you know community is
like brings me I'm true unity you know
people always take my kindness for we
could someone give guy I'm a kind guy
but uh I'm also the [ __ ] most [ __ ]
up person in the world do you know these
people who do work hard is I feel a lot
of guilt because sometimes they get into
places they're like oh [ __ ] this person
works every day of their life they get
up every day and and they work their
asses off to just try and provide for
their families in and I didn't even
realize what I did until it's way too
late I'm like damn I took all this from
these really probably good people that
would give you the clothes off their
back you know and it's like that's what
I want to change I just want to hit that
one big one hit the lottery one time BAM
and be able to just give you know take a
little bit for myself to be comfortable
and to be able to finance my dreams you
know my mighty endeavors but I also want
to give back to the you know people who
truly do deserve it
[Music]
awesome thank you sir
thank you this kind of a I'm not used to
it
thank you not I mean I preach it every
day but people don't really care just he
was like seems like a lot of them now
here they respect you know anyone
but if it's a man that'd be so cool like
my daughter I think I got to go turn
myself and I'm going to turn myself in
on a bunch of the dumb [ __ ] I've done
because I need to get my health back I
need to get a real surgeon like see I
was really known for their health care
get my leg fixed
but I have to bite the bullet and man it
from the dumb that [ __ ] I did Noah but
I've spent quite a bit in jail and I
looked at I'm looking at prison time so
if you turn yourself in and he's prison
that quite possible yeah but I'm willing
to sacrifice it to make sure that I can
be there in the leader years because I
actually cared about my life it is now
you know I just wish that one day I
could just go and get a lot of dollar
scratch ticket for like the 25,000 or
sorry [ __ ] for it but it will see
alright thank you so much